cause you know that 50 cal round Bart is
no yeah
dude do you guys go sayonara yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
episode of careful boys lucky for us we
have Trung Wen back with us
so let's get on with the story you were
telling us about your first time being
deployed what was that like
it was the that was G watt global war on
terror [__] era I mean if you wanted
to fight that was the time to [__]
fight 2000 this is 2004 early 2000s this
is when the war kicked off this is when
if you if you want to get it in this is
when you get it in and they they
wouldn't send us to anywhere that was
[__] easy wherever there was [__]
there wherever there was Mayhem send the
[__] Rangers so we're out there with
uh C Squadron which is uh a squadron in
Delta Force so we're out there with sea
Squadron in the same so we're in in a
compound in a compound so there's the
main compound of where all the soldiers
all you know wherever uh service members
then there's a special operations
compound inside of there and you need an
ID to get in and we went in there I'll
be honest with you it was a lot they
treated us a nice we had like a [__]
Conex with like two bunk beds uh air
conditioning oh wow all you can eat
every uh Friday Saturday Sunday is steak
Lobster damn all the [__] rippets you
could [__] drink you're like this is
what I signed up for
yeah
my buddy in the Navy said the same thing
when he was deployed like in the on the
weekends on the on the ship they would
just get lobster and steak yeah yeah
there was a tote in there
I was like really that blew my mind you
get lobster and steak in the military I
know that that's pretty cool I think
what why they do that is they know that
those troops are in war yeah and they
can they can and they can [__] die
anytime right not so nice I'm glad my
tax dollar is going there though because
like give them something to eat on the
weekends because that might be their
last meal that's Genius Like that's nice
yeah I didn't think about it that way
yeah that's true were most of your
missions you guys jumping on the planes
most of them are so we did zero [__]
jumping out of planes when we're over
there uh all of our missions were direct
action land at that time tactics has
changed though I can't discuss what the
tactics are obviously because I want to
keep the troops safe we're still
deployed uh but at the time of when we
went it was landing on the X and if you
guys don't know what land on the X means
is if this is the house that we're gonna
hit we're going to land directly little
birds Blackhawks fast roping [__]
Vehicles Landing right where we're at
get out the car ex put [__] breaching
charge explosive breach uh you know
speed surprise violence of action just
bum rush the [__] up [__] them up
[Laughter]
it's not like when a gamer is describing
it he was really there and we had soft
shell Humvees at the time we didn't have
like up armor Humvees at the time and a
lot of our missions were nighttime
because of Black Hawk Down
because of the 160 of which is a unit
inside the Army is a special operations
Aviation unit like the best Pilots of
the world best [__] Pilots ever
they clock in more time under night
vision than a [__] airline pilot that
flies wow wow they are they will
literally land this [__] little bird
on the edge of the [__] building in
between buildings where there's like
no room for a [__] up and they'll just
[__] come on down and drop you off
and you [__] go do your thing did you
have night vision or were you are you
like night vision naturally yeah
as you can tell by my eyes I can hardly
see
[Laughter]
the small eyes but no
but uh we we uh like you train to see at
night better like I don't know like no
we knew side Vision oh so the whole
everyone has night vision everybody has
night vision yeah so what time do these
missions take place at like 10 o'clock
at night yeah no we usually we hit them
while they're sleeping
so we'll plan we'll plan to hit at that
time we had the technology to pinpoint
the cell phones that they were using so
we'll we'll like we'll look for their
this high value Target and they were
able to pinpoint them down to the black
wow of where they're so there will be
like a couple of homes they're like okay
so the signal is somewhere right here so
we will plan to hit on these multiple
complexes at the same time so all the
homes are getting hit like at the same
time yeah we're [__] them up so
anybody within that vicinity is just
getting either captured yeah
captured or swiss cheese or swiss cheese
for sure that's the professional
tournament but if they go
wait are they okay yeah of course we're
gonna take them into custody you know
we're not gonna like blindly just shoot
somebody in the face yeah
so wait to say foreign
damn that's crazy international law is
this or this come on come on home base
home base and then most of your missions
do they last like is it like 30 minutes
an hour a whole night it really depends
on if that follow-on mission leads to
another hit wow sometimes we come back
and we we get ready for another one we
have to go back out there multiple
missions a night wow oh yeah a night I
mean it was like getting After Time
After Time and I'll be honest the most
hairiest times that we got into were
during the days though we would do I
would say 90 nighttime hits
but there were certain times when we had
to do daytime this because of that high
value Target is going to squirt and
[__] get out of town and we need to
get that [__] so we the the day
times the ones were the worst is it
because it's dangerous huh is it
dangerous very dangerous because it's
it's daylight they see us coming it's a
bunch of [__] civilian mixed with
with whoever we're dealing with and it's
like uh the Vietnam era which is like
guerrilla warfare you don't know who you
don't know who the good guys you don't
know who the bad guys are uh I remember
one Mission we hit during the day uh
this dude was gonna bounce we did again
we landed on the ax uh we took uh we
took fire right away uh we start
engaging one of the dudes one of the
[__] [__] shot at the 160 of uh
Little Bird one of the rounds actually
won in their ricocheted off the cockpit
hit the dude right in his [__] leg
and basically they had to take off and
take him to get patched up we got the
dude we were pulling out and we're going
down this one-way Street
and I remember vividly because we're I
was a second home being there there was
this [__] 95 maroon Camry
about one Blocker in front of us we saw
him get out of the complex like the
driveway and start reversing back at us
at a high rate of speed and so we're
like hey Tango Tango Tango so he hit the
first Humvee and we saw a cloud of smoke
up here in the back of the trunk they
had a explosive they had they had
explosives that didn't go off there was
[__] there yeah it was a dud it was a
whatever for God God damn we're looking
in So what had happened was after that
happened we backed up into a [__] via
fighting V and we had 50 cows at the
time these are [__] machine guns oh
yeah and there were three of them in the
car so they knew that it didn't go off
so they stuck their AKs out and they
[__] started spraying at us yeah wow
and we just we [__] let them have it
dude that that was the first time I ever
seen actual [__] body parts
flying from the Cars because you know
that 50 cal round Bart is no [__] job
yeah
dude yeah so it was ripping body parts
yeah we [__] them up and we you guys
go sayonara yeah
[Laughter]
didn't you say that a 50 cal even if it
doesn't actually touch you could still
get 100 massively yeah
imagine a whole a belt fit [__] yeah
that's insane yeah getting like oh yeah
so before that when you were like doing
these missions it was like to apprehend
it wasn't like to assassinate no it's
killer capture it's on them if they want
to be killed or not yeah so so then if
there were targets like they would get
shot but then this is the first time you
saw people explode yeah oh like actual
body parts like you're seeing seeing arm
flying or something I was like wow I was
like oh [__] you know yeah and the
targets that they go after like regular
infantry they're just fighting the
Warren kind of like pushing the lines
back and forth they have you guys have
like just signed targets oh yeah like
this is the right hand man to this guy
this is this guy so they're the high
value yeah they're doing Intel Recon and
identify who the key leaders are and
it's not like ground troops just trying
to push the line forward
we had three letter agencies with us
let's I just put it that way I can't say
okay
you know we do what we do we turn up
turn over to them they do UPS yeah UPS
FedEx FedEx KFC KFC
yeah those three letter agencies
so how do you depend on like I always I
was always curious on how you figure out
that all of the Intel is accurate
we let's just say our intelligence
in America it's very good
we have key assets that work these
angles wow so it's like confirmed yeah
and they feed it to us and we just go
after them we're we're there [__]
working dogs they do want to put it that
way you know they they gather their
Intel
then they [__] disseminated to
Special Operations depending on what who
it is what it is and then we just had a
business
tattletales
do you ever feel like all right like I
don't know I'm just trying to picture
myself as a guy like you special ops I'm
learning all of this stuff and I'm
finally deployed and then you said you
didn't even jump once did you feel like
man I did all that jumping and I'm not
they don't even use me can you use me
for jumping like do you feel like you
want to use those things you learn but
then you can't you know we use a lot of
our assets that we that we did learn oh
but the thing is the jumping the last
time we really did a jump like that was
World War II you know like like a
parachute yeah
they're still there's units out there
that operate smaller than we are four
man five-man teams that do have to jump
Behind Enemy Lines and they do do that
which is Bart knows Halo Halo Halo is
high altitude low opening meaning you'll
jump from let's say 25 000 feet and then
when you get to a low altitude that's
when you open hey ho is you're jumping
you're jumping out and you're at a
certain out the tooth that's really high
you open your shoe and you just navigate
your way through into the where you're
at and the reason why they do that is so
that the rate the enemy's Radars won't
be able to pick up the troops and that's
and those guys are just there for
majority of the time reconnaissance to
gather Intel for bigger hits that we
would do are they like the Scout guys
pretty much like they're set up the
Recon guys yeah like they're like
because in the Rangers we have something
called rrc Rangers reconnaissance crew
so that's what they do they they go out
there smaller units they they do like
more Intel driven he doesn't like to
sleep with pajama pants
[Laughter]
I have a question
you know how you were saying that
throughout all the different levels of
boot camp and people drop out and did
you get to the actual like war zone and
notice a person didn't have what it
takes at that point oh like it did all
they passed all the training but just
there yeah you know luckily with the
team that I had no but does it happen
yes yeah uh one of my guy one of my best
friends who stayed in and I left they
went to Afghanistan and they had this
dude who passed all the training and
they were on this uh hike up the [__]
mountains in the [__] snow he quit
right there
he [__] said he just dropped his Rook
side he's like I'm done in Afghanistan
in Afghanistan during a [__]
Mission and the [__] platoon starting
like you're finishing this [__] thing
after you finish this we're gonna
[__] send you back you're getting
[__] you're getting kicked out of the
unit you know you're gonna get kicked
out the unit and you're gonna get sent
to the big army you're gonna get article
15. they're gonna you know they're gonna
do everything to you but yeah he quit
right there on the [__] mountains
what's article 15. it's like a so it's
if you get in trouble in the military
let's say you've got a DUI or you beat
your husband or somebody like that you
get this thing that is just like a mark
a bad mark on your record and it's gonna
affect your promotion status so you want
to make Sergeant you want to go higher
they're going to look at your records to
see if you're clean or not did she say
be your husband yeah
my mind was like stuck there I was like
I was wondering what are you I was like
okay so they don't like that either good
you gotta be nice to your husband I'm
not gonna tell him anything man what a
thing to quit at that point yeah man
that's crazy can you guys get out there
is it a fresh new group or do you get
thrown into veteran groups and then
you're the new guy that they train are
you talking about as a whole unit yeah
into the uh when you're deployed yeah
because it's like are they gonna let the
whole five-man team that's brand new
work together or are they gonna place
you as like the new guy in the veteran
team and then they like they help you
show you the robot kind of thing like
because when I bet it's different right
from training to actual right so how how
it works is when you get to your unit
if you're so our group was about like 11
guys then did they would disseminate us
throughout the different platoons
different squads of veterans so we'll be
with them we'll train up with them
they'll show us the ropes and whatnot
then after we're ready we're gonna
deploy with them so that's going to be
your unit how different was it from
training to real life I'll be honest
with you training is a lot harder than
real life and it's done that way on
purpose makes sense think about like
think about like if you're like like you
you do Jiu Jitsu right when you're
preparing for your let's say a
competition a you know a jiu jitsu
competition You're Gonna Roll with the
best yeah you're gonna seek out camps or
if you're in a getting ready to fight
this big ass MMA fight they're not gonna
go train with mediocre [__] Fighters
they're gonna go seek out people with
special professions boxing wrestling the
top tier of that uh art so that if you
train this high in training the standard
and in real time it's like this it's
[__] too easy but if you wait for war
and Wars like this to you and your
trainees like this when you go there
you're going to get decimated you always
want to make your training it's it's
hard or it's harder than real life so
that when you go out there this is
nothing to you anymore like oh I did the
worst because I can tell you there was
there was a time he went to yakuman
which is uh a [__] a mimic desert
Town out in the middle of [__] uh
east of Washington State
and we were out there doing day uh day
hits Night hits and and we have to do a
rock March into a stress shoot and stay
up for like almost all day and all night
and we only got to eat one meal
I never got to experience that type that
level of hardship when I was over there
really you know what I mean besides
getting getting shot at by real gun
bullets yeah like in terms of like
physical mental I felt so prepared I was
felt so prepared for it like they say
when your training kicks in this is how
it is when you do jits man your train
just [__] gets it it's not a new
experience when it matters the most no
you just you know what to do I would
have been screaming yeah
so how did you end up transitioning to
doing like Chicago SWAT but even between
that LAPD and all that like what made
you go like you know what I think I'm
done with my Army Career you're like how
did that uh haul all happen you know I
started when I was a teenager a young
teenager in the in the streets man I was
playing b-ball with my buddies on on the
corner just hanging out you know uh
being kids out late when you hang out in
that type of environment you grew up not
trusting the police
you know and all my friends and you know
their brothers and cousins they're like
oh [__] the police don't trust them they
were called 5-0 at the time before now
they call 12. don't trust 5-0 blah blah
blah blah so we're just like hanging out
and this one Squad carve pulled up next
to us like oh [__]
he got out the car he came up and he
introduced himself to us he's like hey
I'm officer assessing such this is the
beat I Patrol you know I know you guys
live here but it's dangerous out here
you guys shouldn't be out here after
this time because you know there's been
a couple of homicides that happened you
guys should watch out for each other get
get it home if you guys ever need
anything let me know here's my business
card so that really that cool guy yeah
so
so he sing yeah you know as gay as it
might sound
okay
like a man
shake me down dude yeah so
yeah it's true is that the kind of copy
you wanted to be yeah you know that made
an impact in my life like this dude
don't even know me he could have just
drove away but he took the time out to
come out introduce himself and did all
this like dude this is something I I
want to do some someday to do something
like this to give back so I I reached a
a fork in the road when I was in the
military and War affects everybody
differently right you know I lost I lost
two of my close friends over there
um there were I mean these guys were
studs man you want to talk about when I
got into the range of regimen there were
guys on the [__] teens with already
four [__] deployments to Afghanistan
to Iraq I mean 24 years old getting
after it you know and these guys were
like the epitome of a [__] Ranger
and they got killed and
it affected me so different I was like
dude
I I can't you know I I want to continue
my service after my uh my service time
was up my contract
but I was like I I gotta get out man and
at the same time my mom needed my help
because you know she was a single parent
now she was getting older so I decided
with that and what what had happened
with me the trauma that I dealt with in
the military I got out what year was
that oh that was 2007. oh wow yeah so
when I got out I'll be honest with you
man that first year was horrible man
like I I got used to such a high-paced
life right yeah I try to go to college
it's a [__] workout and the kids
there didn't understand me uh I I was
dealing with so much trauma of I had no
one to talk to yeah so I spent that year
staying at home drinking by myself
dealing with [__] inner demons wow
and did VA provide anything nothing 2007
no one was talking about psychology the
way that it's open now yeah 2007
everyone's like you're a little [__]
that's what they'll say to you figure it
out you know yeah it was it was
different man and you know the whole
suicide thing in the military and
everything is real yeah because there's
no outlet for these guys or gals to talk
to anybody and they and they turn to
drinking and drinking is only like a
Band-Aid on the [__] big wound where
like like what's it's a depressant even
worse yeah you're you're pushing into
that wound even more so yeah I was in a
dark place for a whole [__] year damn
and then you know I started taking Jiu
Jitsu I went to New Breed out in Chicago
and uh
one of the detectives I was rolling with
he was a skulky cop and I you know I was
like
he I found he was a [__] cop and I
was like hey man I'm interested in being
a police officer you know where I can
start and he started printing out some
applications like you should apply for
these departments and I did and I
applied for this department which is a
Suburban Department Park Ridge they were
uh they were looking for three cops so
there's like 200 applicants and I was
one of the three that got hired Dale wow
yeah so I worked with them for about a
year and a half
um it was a real rich neighborhood this
is where Hillary Clinton grew up so it
was like real Rich real boring I was a
rookie cop I was like [__] man I can't
start my career this way I want a run
and Gun I want to be coming from Iraq
Bridge that's crazy totally opposite
yeah I know it's special the high is low
yeah so I applied for at the time
Chicago Police was hiring an LAPD was
always hiring so I applied for both of
them and Chicago was a two-year lottery
so it doesn't matter how well you did on
the test you're in this little Lottery
system and it'll call you every two
years yeah it's we're weird but for La I
flew out I went to Long Beach I applied
from uh from the time I I applied to the
time I got to the police academy with
six months they need officers here so
they're always in need of more oh God
more now than ever you know back then
was like 2010 so then you could still be
the police you know yeah so I got to
work uh I worked at Olympic division
which is uh K-Town okay so I worked
K-Town you know and I dude got to beat
the police LAPD [__] you know I lived
out in Huntington Beach because you
could live anywhere so I was the OC boy
you know I was going up to work and it
was it was fun I enjoyed it uh but wait
was this 2009 this was about 2010 2011.
uh yeah were you a pretty cool cop down
in K-Town man dude I'll be honest I'm
one of those [__] cops bro that's
like hey man look I'm a regular [__]
person just because I got on this
goddamn uniform doesn't make me better
than you yeah you know what I mean I
don't have this Power Trip like oh I am
officer or such and such you should
respect my authority no I'm gonna talk
to you like a human being that's cool
until you [__] show me otherwise yeah
and
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah so did that
but my mom needed like I try to move my
mom to Cali she wouldn't want to go no
she didn't because she didn't know how
to drive you know the high the freeway
system and everything like that so yeah
I had to come back home so I left like
because I was my my goal was LAPD LAPD
SWAT because after the movie SWAT with
Colin Fair I'll do it I was like I'm
[__] doing this [__]
I'm gonna do a [__] Hondo roll you
know what I mean you're very influenced
by videos
[Laughter]
so you went back to do you have to go to
academy twice or like once you go to One
Police Academy you're good that was my I
went to three police academies what the
[__] yeah every single time every single
time uh I went to the first one graduate
top of my class top physical fitness uh
top recruit left there went to LAPD
graduated top of my class one top
officer top in tactics top in physical
fitness got him nice
we've been fighting with this fly for
like the last five minutes but yeah but
Chicago wouldn't accept any of that I
would have to go through their places oh
you got to do it again every time yeah
so but they're all easy as [__] compared
to what yeah yeah it is it is but uh you
know I I didn't I didn't want to go in
there with a chip on my shoulder because
I wasn't that type of individual I
treated that as hey day one day Zero I'm
a newbie even though that's pretty
humble though because like some people
would achieve those things they're like
this is cake like why do I have to do
the yeah at like Academy because I
wanted to set the standards for my class
because a lot of those people were just
civilians coming into there I see or
like leaving the military like who am I
if I was this dude who did this coming
there and kick my feet up
and just blow it off yeah you know I
that's not the way I was raised and
that's just not the way I operate my
plus I'm sure through your training you
were humbled many times over oh yeah so
that transfers over would you be willing
to share in the next episode your
experiences in swat yeah sure absolutely
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign